Ласкаво просимо до програми У фокусі
Європа Ми раді що ви з нами двічі веде
все більше і більше людей до Європи
багато хто намагається потрапити сюди
небезпечними переправами через
Середземне море
щотижня тисячі людей довіряють свої
життя без чесним переправникам сплачуючи
величезні гроші за переправу на човнах
які ледве придатні для плавання їх мета
краще майбутнє Але знову і знову біженці
та мігранти потрапляють у біду У морі з
драматичними а іноді і трагічними
наслідками
один із тих хто став свідком цих
трагедій Вінченцо Лучано італійський
рибалка
він провів усе своє життя біля моря коли
неподалік від його рідного міста
розбився човен щось зламалося і в ньому
самому
ці 180 пасажирів лише половину вдалося
врятувати з води
більше гнівалися на європейську політику
стосовно біженців що не здатна запобігти
трагедіям подібним до тієї яка сталася
на узбережжі Калабрії поблизу кротоне
на узбережжі Калабрії сталося нещастя
сильний вітер приносить до берега все
більше тіл загиблих через кілька тижнів
після однієї з найсмертоносніших
корабельних аварій за останні
десятиліття біля берегів Італії команди
водолазів доставляють останки до
коренера відомо що загинуло щонайменше
80 людей місцевий рибалка Вінченцо
Лучано досі в шоці Він допомагає
пошуковим групам орієнтуватися в добре
знайомих йому водах він шенцо був одним
із перших на місці подій того фатального
дня я побачив дитину
коли підхопив його і поклав на берег він
був вже мертвим
очі ще були відкритими
я розсердився на себе Якби я не пив каву
то Міг би приїхати на 5 хвилин раніше і
врятувати його
я шокований
той ранок змінилося моє життя
мушель біля його ніг речі які пережили
своїх власників близько 180 мігрантів і
біженців намагалися дістатися з
Туреччини до Італії але їхній
перевантажений човен розбився біля
берега одна трагедія - це вже занадто
каже Вінченцо за останні роки тисячі
людей потонули намагаючись дістатися
Європи Вінченцо рибалить уже майже 4
десятиліття але зараз його Сіті порожні
а човен не відчалює від берега
я не можу повернутися в море
я не можу з цим впоратися перед очима
постають образи тих мертвих тіл і я не
можу змусити себе знову закинути
рибальський Сіті Ну просто не можу
теж бачив тіла він пережив цю катастрофу
і зараз вшановує пам'ять загиблих
вимпровізованому морзі у місцевому
спорткомплексі він досі не може забути
паніку крики і молитви цієї ночі в морі
коли афганці сирійці та іранці втратили
своє життя двоє друзів хасиба загинули
Корабель розбився на шматки
Я вхопився за шматок дерева
ця дошка була даром Божим
Я ніколи не забуду той день
здається тоді я народився заново
сподівається Одного дня почати нове
життя Можливо в Німеччині але за
законами Європейського Союзу люди
повинні просити притулку в цій країні
куди Вони прибули спочатку протягом
багатьох років у блоці існують
розбіжності щодо того чи варто і як
реформувати Ці правила Дехто вважає що
трагедії подібні до цієї яка сталася
біля кротони Це наслідок невдалої
політики катастрофи в морі породжуються
на суходолі коли на калабрію опускається
ніч Франческа Рока виконує свій вечірній
ритуал роздає їжу нелегальним мігрантам
та іншим нужденним а вона каже що
легальних способів потрапити до ЄС
просто замало
уряду дійсно потрібно краще приймати
мігрантів
вони не розглядають імміграцію як
позитивне явище вони кажуть що потрібно
скоротити міграційні потоки замість того
щоб допомагати людям приїжджати
прем'єр-міністрка Італії джорджея
меллоні від ультраправої партії брати
Італії зустрілися з родичами загиблих
після трагедії вона каже що її уряд
невинну трагедії але нам якось моя
совість чиста
ми бачимо що Чим більше людей виїжджає
Чим більше людей віддають себе в руки
цинічних переправників тим більший Ризик
що щось піде не так
Рим просуває суперечливі закони
обмежуючи можливості
пошуково-рятувальних операцій що
проводяться некомерційними групами
стверджуючи що вони спонукають людей до
цих небезпечних подорожей критики
попереджають що це може призвести до
того що іще більше людей потоне але
місцевий мир Антоніо чирасо каже що це
правильний підхід ця проблема повинна
стати принаймні європейською проблемою
одна Італія не може витримати все це
правда що до Італії прибуває більше
мігрантів ніж в інші місця
але очевидно що не всі ці люди хочуть
залишитися в Італії
вони хочуть перебратися до інших країн
він шансон не знає чи набереться він
сміливості щоб знову почати рибалити Він
знову і знову проходить слідами цієї
травми намагаючись рухатись уперед
одна мати прийшла побачитися зі мною Бо
дізналися що і був одним із перших на
березі Тоді
одна з їх доньок була вже мертвою але
вона благала мене знайти другу
тож я повертаюся
щодня ходжу вздовж і впоперек берега
вдень і вночі
рінченцо хоче щоб Калабрія підвела риску
під цією катастрофою Але після багатьох
років дебатів країни є досі надійшли
згоди щодо перегляду політики надання
притулку що на думку багатьох украй
необхідно із моменту цієї корабельної
аварії до Італії прибули ще сотні
мігрантів на невеличких човнах і десятки
людей зникли безвісти або потонули під
час спроби переправитись до Європи
Італія прийняла майже втричі більше
біженців ніж за аналогічний період
минулого року
серед мільйонів людей які втекли від
війни в Україні багато хто знайшов
прихисток в Австрії часто маючи під
рукою лише найнеобхідніше без знання
мови і з порожніми банківськими
рахунками однак у Відні дехто отримав
негайну допомогу від американки Та ні
Маєр яка очікувала на них на
центральному залізничному вокзалі вона
допомагала тисячам українських біженців
і здобула собі ім'я завдяки цьому
на випадок якщо хтось сумнівається що
одна людина може щось змінити запитайте
українських біженців у Відні для яких
одне ім'я стало рятівним кругом Таня
знайдіть Таню Майєр кажуть вони вона вам
допоможе таку пораду отримала і Лілія
від іншої біженки коли залишила свого
сина підлітка у Відні самого перед своїм
поверненням до України
вона сказала Таня допоможе моєму синові
Це моя єдина дитина
[музика]
і я не хочу щоб він загинув на цій війні
має опинилася в цій ролі дещо випадково
незважаючи на попередню кар'єру він
інвестиційному банкінгу протягом
багатьох років Вона була переважно мамою
домогосподаркою але потім Росія
вторглася в Україну 24 лютого я
прокинулася розплакалася проплакала весь
ранок а потім почала стежити за тим що
відбувається хтось написав мені Привіт
Таню якщо ти у Відні Ти маєш піти
допомагати на вокзалі вільно володіючи
російською мовою Маєр допомагала
українцям які прибували до Відня Багато
з них мали Лише кілька речей у
поліетиленових пакетах і майже ніякої
готівки вона почала купувати речі для
людей з власної кишені але рівень потреб
швидко став непосильним біженці
застрягли в центрі прибуття набагато
тижнів замість передбачених трьох днів і
поки вони залишалися там вони не могли
почати отримувати фінансову допомогу
реакція держави була дуже повільною І
абсолютно хаотичною і люди місяцями
чекали на хоч якісь гроші від
австрійського уряду саме тоді народилася
ідея збору коштів на продуктові картки
номіналом по 50 євро разом із кількома
волонтерами Таня Маєр створила веб-сайт
вона вкладає кожну копійку ці
сертифікати розсилаючи Багато з них
вручну і публікуючи фотографії продуктів
які купують отримувачі на сьогоднішній
день Було доставлено близько чотирьох
тисяч карток я була дуже вдячна і
написала їй Таня величезне вам дякую
тому що 50 євро На той час були великими
грошима Ірина каже що подарункова карта
від Майер була першою рукою допомоги яку
вона та її діти отримали в Австрії
діти казали який сюрприз
це ніби привітання з днем народження
це було надзвичайно важливо для нас тому
що тоді я була я була розгубленою
Василь каже що Таня Маєр допомогла і
йому знайти житло коли вони з матір'ю
були без даху над головою зараз він на
волонтерських засадах адміністрає її
онлайн групу
багато людей потребують допомоги Я маю
на увазі що ресурсів не вистачає А вона
ніби тягне все це самотужки
але Майер далеко не самотня потяг Надії
неурядової організація створена для
допомоги у зв’язку з великим напливом
мігрантів у 2015 році на сьогодні
забезпечила їжею одягом житлом та
роботою близько 135 тисяч біженців але
на думку організацій Шкода що ці
завдання знову лягають на плечі
волонтерів Можна було б багато чому
навчитися озираючись на те що
відбувалося у 2015 році але коли у 2022
році приїхали українці побачили що в той
час як ндо та громадянське суспільство
робили свою частину роботи більша
частина керівництва державних органів
влади не зробила цього
дехто також відчуває що первісна
гостинність вичерпала себе ця група
людей з обмеженими можливостями та
важкими захворюваннями живе в будівлі
яку закриють наступного місяця і їм не
сказали що буде далі зараз нас будуть
розселяти і Ми дуже переживаємо що нас
розселять кудись по різним місцям і хто
нам всім буде допомагати
для багатьох відповідно на це питання
знову ж таки Таня але вона каже що її
проект допоміг і їй
і я завжди відчувала що була поганим
прикладом для своїх дітей тому що вже
давно не працювала
та Цього року я була справді хорошим
прикладом я навчила їх що може зробити
одна людина
вони добровільно зголосилися займатися
розмовною практикою з українськими
дітьми їхнього віку і я дуже цим пишаюся
Таня Маєр каже що продовжуватиме
допомагати біженцям доки гроші не
перестануть надходити Але це буде не
сьогодні її телефон розривається від
нових звернень і нових пожертвань і люди
розраховують що Таня зможе дістатися до
поштової скриньки
Франція охоплена заворушеннями мільйони
людей вийшли на вулиці проти президента
еммануеля макрона
пенсійна реформа передбачає що в
майбутньому французи повинні працювати
на два роки довше до 64 років але
опитування показують що більшість
французів не згодні з цим рішенням
студентка Алісія виходить на барикади не
лише на знак протесту проти нових
пенсійних законів які багато інших вона
протестує бо вважає що її не сприймають
всерйоз ні уряд ні президент Франції
[музика]
Алісія ніколи не пропускає протестів як
і мільйони французьких громадян 19-річна
дівчина хоче перешкодити уряду просунути
пенсійну реформу вона хоче щоб люди
могли виходити на пенсію у 62 роки
у деяких країнах виходять на пенсію
навіть у 67 це дуже багато для мене це
історичний момент це одна із найбільших
соціальних мобілізацій за останні 70
років і з травня 68-го і вона спрямована
проти пенсійної реформи людей мають
почути атмосфера в Парижі на половину
фестивалю на половину Революційна деякі
банки забили вікна дошками
вони бояться бруківки та гніву населення
проти президента еммануеля макрона
[музика]
Алісія студентка юридичного факультету
каже що він поводиться як Монарх Вона
злиться що його уряд в обхід парламенту
підвищив пенсійний вік до 60-4 років
вони не хочуть відступати немає Ані
компромісу Ані дебатів навіть профспілки
ігноруються Ось у чому проблема
протягом декількох місяців президента
намагався переконати французів що
пенсійна система потребує більше коштів
ви думаєте Мені подобається ця реформа
сьогодні у нас 17 мільйонів пенсіонерів
У 2030 році їх буде 20 мільйонів Як ви
думаєте чи зможемо ми продовжувати з
нинішніми законами
але згідно із опитуваннями дві третини
французів проти цієї реформи
вони хвилюються за своє майбутнє
[музика]
якщо вже попрацювали 44 роки як і я то у
вас є багато інших справ Окрім роботи
життя вже відносно коротке
протестувальники співають що макрон
оголосив їм війну які Поліція це натяк
на жорсткий поліцейський контроль
протестів
Це моя мама дзвонить
Так це була моя мама вона завжди
хвилюється коли я виходжу на протести
багато французьких економістів
підтримують президента і вважають вимоги
протестувальників абсурдними але деякі
політологи стверджують що існують інші
способи фінансування пенсійних схем
дехто дивиться на інші країни ЄС для
порівняння
у Франції умови праці для багатьох
працівників погіршилися
вони кажуть що не встигають адже тиск
дуже великий
у Німеччині натомість Чому ви праці
покращилися наприклад у промисловості
багато протестувальників кажуть що їх
експлуатує політична система економічна
система і промисловість деякі більша
декально налаштовані демонстранти готові
до боротьби цей протестувальник побажав
залишитися анонімним усі соціальні права
були так чи інакше здобуті шляхом
насильства боротьба за них певною мірою
легітимізує насильство я їх підтримую
молодь розгнівана я старий я на пенсію
але я також дуже розвинений
цей Гнів поділяють десятки тисяч людей
на оперній площі ситуація загострилась
навіть підпалили якийсь непотріб сміття
в Парижі накопичується оскільки
працівники сміттєзбиральних компаній
також протиреформи і вийшли на протест
ситуація хаотична але Алісія
продовжуватиме боротися за кращими
майбутнє принаймні доти доки президент
Не скасує цю реформу це відбулося за
лічені хвилини в десятки тисяч будівель
у Туреччині були пошкодження або
зруйновані сильними землетрусами
пощастило врятуватися сотні тисяч людей
назавжди втратили свої домівки особливо
сильно постраждало місто іскандерун
після землетрусів багато сімей живуть у
наметах наданих державним агентством і
захисту від стихійних лих зокрема і діти
якбинін його життя протікає в умовах
надзвичайної ситуації з якої не видно
жодного виходу
коли-небудь казали що ви схожі на когось
іншого Можливо на кінозірку чи політика
але що буде якщо людина на яку ви схожі
робить щось і З чим ви більше не хочете
асоціюватися
якось цей чоловік
Путіна є двійник який живе у Польщі який
зовсім не в захваті від того ким став
його власний двійник
кава з Путіним А точніше зі славоміром
собакою польським двійником російського
президента
собака каже що його ніколи не сплутаєш
із Путіним
погляд очей Так схожий і можливо губи
але насправді важливі рухи характерна
постава Путіна наприклад його хода
Путін ходить як модель
симетричні сідниці напружені
вище пояси він марширує як
солдатність
А право залишається рівною тому що
офіцери кдб носили зброю з правого боку
вони повинні були мати можливість швидко
до неї дотягнутися
собака керує транспортною компанією це
його основне заняття тривалий час бути
Путіним було для нього радше хобі
принаймні до повномасштабного
російського вторгнення в Україну
Минулого року це стало поворотним
моментом і для нього
звісно я не згоду з тим що робить Путін
нинішньої політичним курсом
не може бути виправдання
ніхто не повинен миритися з конфліктами
в яких гинуть люди
раніше собака знімався в кумедних
рекламних роликах по всьому світу навіть
грав у мюзіклі
але тепер він вважає що це виглядатиме
безглуздо Він став обачним І каже що
його неодноразово ображали його а
точніше його двійника не вітають навіть
з його рідному місті Вроцлаві на кого
схожий цей чоловік Путін злодій Путін
цей псих жахлива людина
Фу я не хочу навіть дивитися на нього
це Путін Чи це хтось інший
як двійника почалася 11 років тому люди
постійно казали йому що він схожий на
Путіна тому він зв'язався з фотографом
двійників зараз він каже що це були інші
часи людям подобалося фотографуватися з
ним але Минулого року собака
дистанціювався від Путіна на своїй
домашній сторінці
Я єдиний хто професійно грає Путіна
живучи не в Росії а у вільні і
демократичні країни
я буду використовувати цю свободу щоб
висміювати цього деспота і його режим Це
єдиний спосіб яким він може допомогти
народу України
Хай живе вільна Україна
тепер собрала ретельно відбирає свої
проекти він більше не хоче валяти дурня
йому потрібні лише серйозні та
відповідальні ролі
у певному сенсі він залишається у ролі
лиходія на цьому Ми закінчуємо цей
випуск У фокусі Європи дякуємо вам за
перегляд від імені всієї команди Бажаємо
вам спокійного тижня і до зустрічі
[музика]
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]